okay so this is a quick video on how to
find HMO properties on Rightmove so we
have got a five-point checklist so the
first thing we're going to do is we're
going to go on to right mukarat UK and
we're going to decide that area now of
course it has to be an area where by
there's a high demand on Sparrow bucket
at UK so usually you already have an
area in mind so in this point we're
going to do
Wasel water Hampton and if we go spare
room if you're looking for an area
outside of Warsaw all over Hampton
you're going to type in a city so we can
try Birmingham rooms wanted search now
and you'll see that there's 572 people
looking there's lots and lots of demands
people looking for rooms if we put
Walsall in here it's not quite the same
as Burma go but the houses are cheaper
but we've still got 69 people looking
with lots of new people which is not too
bad Wolverhampton new today new today
new today we've got people looking more
handsome now this training video is
about how to find properties on
Rightmove not like how to find your
patch because there are certain issues
that there were some areas where you
can't buy HMOs because of our to perform
and things like that so we're just going
to work on the base that we're looking
at so Wolverhampton one second all right
sorry well I just have to tell the guys
next door to be quiet
okay so search this area only price
range if it's less than 60 grand it's
going to be absolutely rubbish it's
going to be run down its with auction so
honestly lose 70 grand
and we're going to go to 1:10 number
bedrooms three property type has to be a
house added to the solids in this case
I'm really anytime if you're doing this
everyday you doing it regularly you
could just every day say what's new in
the last 24 hours
and it's saying you haven't fished
through everything but weathers could do
anytime include under up for souls in
this case know if I was doing every day
I probably would just to see what what
would come up but no so I can great
we've already got a soul property this
come up and I didn't want to see the
soul properties so let's change this to
change your filters click a hair filter
and and it's like anytime
I can't see where the layout of right
now is just change seems to change on a
day-by-day basis so let's do this again
water Hampton this area only 70 grams to
110 three bedrooms houses ah you only
respond ticked right here we go
so straight away I can see that this
house is a good house because it's in
good condition all the looks of things
yeah it's in good condition it's got to
reception rooms sell
Center it doesn't look too far away it
says it's point two miles away from a
train station which is good but how do
we find out if this if the area is good
if it's close to the center but what we
have to do is we have to get the address
now again if it's a really long street
you might need to find out the number
but in this case four straight is just
quite a small street so it will to give
us a clearer indication where it is so
call those people answer we're going to
go on Google we're going to get a map
open and directions and let's type in
Wolverhampton and this will be snap bang
on in the center of all Hampton and it
says it's ten minutes 2.1 miles
however that's when you're driving but
we're not going to be driving we're
going to be taking the bus so there's a
little bus icon here and if we click
that it now says 13 minutes boom that
word forget it's got to be 13 minutes
I'm sorry 15 minutes less from the city
centre so on the bus you can get there
within 15 minutes
so the location works the condition
works it's got four rooms all the four
rooms big enough well let's have a look
one two three
smallest room is ten by six eleven oh
that is just shy of 70 squared fear
needs to be seventy square feet and that
is just shy with being that close I
might be tempted to book it in anyway
but you've got to draw the line
somewhere so let's see just to show you
how this works there's a really nice
little app somewhere I think it's this
one this one will do so it's going to be
ten by six eleven and that is sixty nine
point one six in that if it's that close
I will probably be tempted to just go
ahead and book it so that house pretty
much ticks all the boxes it's on for 110
which is a little high because we're
like 25,000 pounds per room and this is
a tiny bit more than that
so what I intend to do is bring the
agent let's just save the property and
ask then are they open to options it
just say offers in region of so that is
how you find a property we're going to
find one more just to give you guys a
real idea of how this how this works so
these are all 110 so really I mean
ideally we want to go ton cheaper now
this I can see straight away it's
auction which is no good so you always
wanted to have a quick look at the
description for you click into something
again this is bortion unfortunately
there's no way of searching not let's
not look at auction properties I wish
there was so this property here the
conditions good price okay
I always like to look at a floor plan so
you've really three bedrooms and you two
deception rooms but I can already tell
what a floor plan that that bedroom
looks climbing so let's see okay okay so
that Thai name but it is still smaller
than the 70 squared feet you've got your
two reception rooms kitchen three
bedrooms bathroom and an outbuilding WC
which is great but that one room
unfortunately is not going to be big
enough if the property is absolutely
amazing but the only problem is the
smallest bedroom you can move partition
walls sometimes so it might be that you
could literally move this wall and put
it here and then make that room bigger
she was like a really big hallway so
sometimes we can't still be your
properties but you know you don't want
to waste time you don't want to clutch
at straws let's see if we can see a
picture of this hallway upstairs
there isn't a picture of the hallway so
yeah I mean it's okay
it doesn't Meijin Xie I mean it yeah
it's decent condition the kitchen looks
pretty small it's okay you can possibly
make it work but it's not an absolutely
amazing one so let's see what else we
got
right hardy square okay condition looks
okay
was a really quick way to let it go I
can see straight away this is no good
because it's got three bedrooms and
third bedrooms too small it's only got
one reception room again if that
reception room was absolutely massive
and this room is big you could put a
partition wall and turn into two but in
this case it's just not going to work
right this one again this looks very
country so let's have a quick look the
area it doesn't look like the areas good
it's two point eight miles from the
nearest train station and I can see
straight away this is way too far out of
the town for it to work so that one's
not going to work all right that one's
not going to work you see this is a it
can be very time-consuming especially
when you're looking at loads but what
you'll find is if you do this every day
it will probably only take you like
maybe 10 20 minutes to do an area so
it's not that bad right this one it's
annoying it's not many pictures it's got
to reception rooms it looks like it's in
a good location it's not too far but I
can because it's on an offer main road
it's always good if it wasn't like here
it'll be no good but because it's off
the main road that is not bad let's do a
route planner and see how far away it is
so it's Douglas place it's all you're
going to do is you're going to type in
Douglas place warm Hampton from warm
Hampton okay 16 minutes so it's it kind
of joy just over and now it was
absolutely perfect four bedroom two
hundred gram really it in 16 minutes you
might in order to let that pass because
say a minute over when you start being
too compromising when everything that's
when you can simply have slightly bad
properties so with this one the area's
kind of just throughout potentially
that's practically no description on the
condition or on the sizes and see if
there's a brochure sometimes that can be
more details if you click on the
brochure and there's very little so in
this case I bring up the agent and I
just say what's the condition like
what's the crack what are the room one
of the room measurements and things like
that but we can't really be excited
about that with so little details let's
have a look at this one color down the
road I bought one in Caledonia Road
alright before
conditions look sprays yeah absolutely
brilliant but what else you've got a
dining room you've got a modern an
allowance and a kitchen diner brilliant
let's see the very measurements I always
rush did you see the third room further
rooms big brilliant one two three big
rooms kitchen diner okay this could be a
fine bed because you could potentially
do the kitchen diagur as your communal
area and then turn these both into a
bedroom I know the area is good but
let's just click on it and I'll be able
to show you so again you can see that
it's really close to the center I can
tell without doing a planner that this
one's going to be okay but if you wanted
to do a planner now Caledonia Road how
big is it okay so it's not too big it's
quite small remember if it's a really
big road you're going to find the door
number and do an exact route planner but
in this case because Caledonia Road is
not big you can see I've already found
that two or three good properties just
in the last 12 10 minutes so okay it's
11 minutes on the bus to the center and
you can walk it in 23 minutes that's a
good sign
that's a good sign so the the location
is brilliant the condition is brilliant
and price is brilliant
and you've got three bedrooms and two
reception rooms and that is one that we
need
- get in - absolutely ASAP so as you can
see in the last sort of you know ten
minutes or so I found two or three good
properties and that is what we wanting
to do so every day living off them
that's how you find properties so just
do a kind of recap and go over the five
boxes location it needs to be 15 minutes
from within the center usually that's
within one and a half miles away there
needs to be four-letter ballrooms
minimum and they need to be at least 70
square feet the maximum asking price is
305 I mean if you sort of look at the
properties at one for 115-120 it's just
it's just not gonna it's just not gonna
fly
and also year last thing no auction
properties no fifty percent shares and
they've cash offers only just read the
description and just check that there's
no catches no problems before saving it
and then that is how you find HMOs
online